découvrir une toute nouvelle espèce les
bouche trous
des animaux trop mignon joueur
est très intelligent
cette année
les bouche-trous débarque chez vous si
jamais vu un endroit pareil
tu es là c'est le petit sénat non c'est
trop dangereux mélomane et mouscron
le voyage complètement dingue
allez viens on a encore plein lieu à un
traité alors on reste concentré pour
sauver leur espèce
on est les seuls à pouvoir sauver les
bouche trous de l'extinction pauvres de
nous
oc cracra
alors
on sera considérée comme des rangs
bon ça
perle rf lettre
les bouche trous on va tomber mon temps
[Musique]
mais grave les gars c'est juste un donut
mindy d'enée délicieux bientôt au cinéma